it's just a nightmare
complete nightmare
in a bitterly cold rented flat in
Yorkshire this father who we're calling
Peter is surrounded by mold and damp
he's afraid of eviction if he complains
so we're protecting his identity like
many struggling with energy costs Peter
is often forced to go without Heating
and at night he resorts to Shared bodily
warmth for him and his two teenage Sons
we're just sold sleeping on their
mattresses on the floor
all into one room
I just got to that point now I think the
boys would be better off without me
they might get a bit more better care
because I'm struggling
these photos show how bad the mold
problem was Peter's landlord took some
remedial measures but they haven't
stopped the problem I think well if I
approach him too much he's gonna think
oh no and just get someone else in
there's a real problem with damp and
mold in private rented homes more than
one in ten of issues with dab according
to new figures from the English housing
survey with Yorkshire and the Humber
much worse than the rest of England
social housing is badly hit too figures
from the social housing Watchdog shared
exclusively with Sky News paint a
worrying picture
there were a record three and a half
thousand complaints relating to mold
damp and leaks in social housing in the
year to March 2022 but between April and
November this year there were more than
two and a half thousand complaints a
rate that if it continues will surpass
the record figure I think it is clearly
profoundly concerning that you're seeing
a significant rise in the number of
people who are reporting uh issues with
damper mold people who are bringing
raising complaints about damper mold are
often saying this is having an impact on
their health it's having an impact on
their mental health is I have an impact
on their well-being that's causing them
deep distress anxiety uh and
embarrassment the UK has the oldest
housing stock in Europe with soaring
energy costs forcing vulnerable people
like Peter to leave the heating off the
presence of damp and mold will continue
to pose a real and significant health
risk this winter
Stephen Murphy Sky News in Yorkshire